hello everyone and welcome back to our
Channel today I've got something really
exciting to discuss that is the AI road
map for 2024 artificial intelligence has
been evolving at an incredible pace and
2024 promises to be a groundbreaking
year in the world of AI so let's Dive
Right into what we can expect in the
coming year and before that if you're
one of the aspiring python Enthusiast or
a ml Enthusiast that is looking for
online training and graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
elicits to switch careers in Ai and ml
by learning from the experts then try
giving a short to Simply learns
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning in collaboration with per
University and IBM the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete
overiew of the program being offered and
if you like these videos then like share
And subscribe to our Channel and now
starting with who is an AI professional
so an AI professional is an expert in
the field of artificial intelligence
possessing the Knowledge and Skills to
design develop and Implement AI
solutions they play a crucial role in
various Industries leveraging AI
Technologies to solve complex problems
and enhance decision-making process they
are in high demand due to the increasing
use of AI in Industries like healthcare
Finance sence and technology and now we
will explore the various career paths
for an AI professional starting with AI
research scientist then we have machine
learning engineer data scientist NLP
engineer computer vision engineer AI
ethics and bias analyst AI product
manager AI software developer so these
are the career paths for an AI
professional now we'll move to the roles
and responsibilities for each profession
so starting with AI research s scientist
so the roles and responsibilities are
conduct research to advance Ai and
machine learning Technologies then we
have developed and Implement Noel
algorithms and models and another work
is integrate AI into products and
services and then publish research
findings in conferences and journals
then stay updated with the latest
developments in AI research so these are
the roles and responsibilities for AI
research scientist now moving on to the
next role that was machine learning
engineer and now we'll see its tools and
responsibilities that is design and
build machine learning models and
systems collect and pre-process data for
model training tune and optimize
algorithms for performance deploy models
into production environments and monitor
and maintain machine learning systems
and now moving on to the next role that
is data scientist data scientist roles
and responsibilities are as
follows the analyze large data set to
extract many meaningful insights they
develop predictive models and data
driven Solutions and they create data
visualizations and reports for decision
making they collaborate with business
teams to identify data driven
opportunities they also ensure that data
privacy and security compliance keep in
handy and now moving on to the next Ro
that is natural language processing
engineer NLP engineer and their roles
and responsibilities are they develop
NLP models for language and
understanding and generation they
pre-process and clean Text data for NLP
task they work on sentiment analysis
chat boards and language translation
they collaborate with linguist and
domain experts for specialized NLP
projects they stay current with NLP
research and Technologies and now moving
on to the next Ro that is computer
vision
engineer so the computer vision engineer
build computer vision algorithms for
image and video analysis they develop
object detection image recognition and
facial recognition systems they
collaborate with Hardware teams for
embedded Vision applications they
Implement image and video processing
techniques they also stay updated on
computer vision advancements so these
were the roles and responsibilities for
computer vision engineer now moving on
to the next role that is AI ethics and
bias analyst so starting with their
roles and responsibilities the first one
is assess and mitigate ethical concerns
and biases in AI systems develop and
implement fairness and bias detection
algorithms and show AI systems that
comply with ethical guidelines and
regulations they educate teams on
ethical AI practices and they conduct
Audits and assessments of AI models now
moving on to the next role that is AI
product manager now moving on to the
next role that is AI product manager and
now we'll see their roles and
responsibilities so they Define the AI
product strategy and road map they
collaborate with stakeholders to GA
requirements and they prioritize
features and functionalities for AI
products they also manage the
development and deployment for AI
solutions they also monitor product
performance and gather user feedback now
moving on to the next tole that is AI
software developer so AI software
developer develop software applications
that incorporate AI capabilities they
integrate Ai apis and libraries into
existing software systems they write
code for AI model deployment and
inference
they collaborate with AI researchers and
Engineers on software projects they
debug and maintain AI related code and
applications these roles and
responsibilities can vary depending on
the specific industry I'm talking about
all the roles they can vary on specific
industry organization and the level of
expertise required so AI professionals
may also specialize further Within These
roles based on their areas of interest
and expertise and now I have an insight
for you guys that is if you are one of
the inspiring AI or ml enthusiasts
looking for online training or
graduating from the best universities
then I have the short of Simply learn
skelic a& ml boot camp and you can find
the boot camp details with the link and
you will navigate to The Boot Camp Page
now moving to the career road map for AI
professional so these are the steps you
need to follow to become an AI
professional so the step one is
mastering the fundamentals then we have
introduction to machine learning then
the third step is deling deeper into
deep learning then we have practical
experience with data then introduction
to natural language processing and then
we have immersion in computer vision and
then introduction to reinforcement
learning and then engage in Practical
projects and continuous learning so
starting with the step one so what
should you do to be a AI professional so
the first step is mastering the
fundamentals so begin your AI journey by
establishing a strong foundation in Core
Concepts get acquired with essential
mathematical principles such as algebra
calculus and probability additionally
take the time to become proficient in a
beginner friendly programming language
like python which is widely utilized in
the field of AI explore various online
tutorials and education resources to
grasp the fundamental aspects of Python
Programming now moving to step two that
is Introduction to machine learning so
machine learning constitutes a pivotal
component of AI start by comprehending
the concepts of supervised and
unsupervised learning supervised
learning involves the training of models
using label data while unsupervised
learning revolves around the
identification of patterns within
unlabeled data familiarize yourself with
popular machine learning algorithms like
linear regression and decision trees
prioritize gaining an intuitive
understanding of these algorithms before
delving into their mathematical incases
and now moving on to the step three that
is delving deeper into deep learning
deep learning has witnessed significant
Acclaim in recent years commence your
deep Learning Journey by acquiring
knowledge about neural networks the
fundamental building blocks of deep
learning gain insight into the structure
of neural networks the data learning
mechanisms and their predictive
capabilities explore crucial Concepts
like activation functions back
propagation and gradient descent so this
was about the step three now we'll move
to the step four that is practical
experience with data so data is the
lifeblood of AI applications learn how
to efficiently manipulate and
pre-process data discover techniques for
data cleaning addressing missing values
and transforming data into formats
suitable for model training put your
skills into practice by working with
libraries like pandas and numpy which
simplify data manipulation task now
moving on to the step five that is
Introduction to natural language
processing natural language processing
is focused on enabling machines to
comprehend human language begin by
building a foundation in in essential
NLP Concepts such as tokenization the
division of text into words or sentences
stemming reducing words to their root
forms and part of speech tagging
identifying grammatical elements gain
practical experience by experimenting
with NLP libraries like nltk now moving
on to the step six that is immersion in
computer vision so computer vision
involves the teaching of machines to
interpret visual information Begin by
exploring image processing techniques
including fil Ing and feature extraction
learn about widely used computer vision
algorithms such as object detection and
image classification creat put your
knowledge into action by experimenting
with libraries like open CV and
tensorflow to implement computer vision
applications now moving on to the step
seven that is Introduction to
reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning centers on training agents to
make decisions through a process of
trial and errow start by understanding
Core Concepts such as rewards States and
actions familiarize yourself with
popular algorithms like Q learning and
engage in the environments like open AI
gym to practice reinforcement learning
then we have the step eight engaging in
Practical projects and continuous
learning apply your new found knowledge
through Hands-On projects begin with
small scale projects and progressively
take on more complex challenges
participate in AI communities and
contribute to online forums to
collaborate with fellow Learners and
gain insights from experienced
practitioners stay updated with the
latest developments in AI by following
AI blogs attending webinars and
exploring AI related new sources so in
conclusion I want to say that commencing
your AI Journey as a no ice may appear
daunting but by following this
structured road map you can progress
systematically and establish a solid
foundation in AI Concepts remember to
prioritize a deep understanding of the
fundamentals engage in Hands-On learning
with real world data and undertake
projects to reinforce your knowledge
Embrace continuous learning and leverage
online resources and and communities to
enhance your AI skills now moving on to
the companies hiring AI professional so
Amazon Cap Gemini orle TCS asenta sap
IBM cognizant so these are the companies
and these are the top most companies
that hire AI
professionals and now moving on to the
average salary for AI professionals so
in us a bner AI professional can earn up
to $882,000 to
$128,000 and then experienced
professional can earn from
$99,000 to
$200,000 and if we talk about India a
beginner can earn from 5 lakhs to 12
lakhs perom and if we talk about the
experienced professional they can earn
from 7 lakhs to 20 lakhs per anom so
these data are just the stats from the
glass door and they can vary on the
different states and the countries so
well there you have it folks and before
ending I want to take your a minute to
hear from our Learners who have
experienced massive success in their
careers by opting out the boot camp and
the postgraduate program in Ai and
machine
learning you need to keep updating your
skills the course material was
comprehensive and the faculty was
extremely experienced uh The Faculty was
able to adjust their teaching style in
order to cater to the overall skill set
of the class in the rapidly evolving
world of technology it's important to
keep upskilling for every working
professional stay relevant continue
learning and if you like this session
then like share and subscribe if you
have any questions then you can drop
them in the comment section below thanks
for watching and stay tuned for more
from Simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs and cut Cutting
Edge domains including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here